[拍手]
人生に埋め
心に情熱を
みなさんこんにちは
さあ早速ですが突然皆さんに夢を聞きたい
と思います
皆さんにねお持ちですか
夢があるという方
はいありがとうございますじゃあ聞いてみ
ましょう
それでは
ですね行きましょうか
はいはにがありますか
大会でもう一度働いてみたいな海外でもう
一度遠田過去に働いた事があるって事です
かね
ああそうですかはいありがとうございます
皆さんいいですね夢っていいですよね
あの誰かの夢を聞いているだけで元気を
いただけます
それに夢を持つ女に年齢生です c は
一切関係ありませんん誰しもが自由に夢を
持つことができます
それ
我々にんがもし
夢やリスを持たない生き物だったら私たち
は今どんな生活をしているでしょう
おそらくこういう生活をすると思います
ちょっと困りますね
はい
はいそれから私たちは皆誰かの夢の上でて
います例えば
もっと速くもっと東京行きたいがそんな胸
を描いた方々がバイクを作りそして自動車
を作りそして飛行機を作りました
いつでもどこでも遠くの人と自由に話がし
たいな
そんな夢を開いた人たちが携帯秒の作り
スマホを作りました
今回はこのテックス博多も様々な人の話
からいろんなヒントを得ていただきたい
そんなスタッフの方々の弓は思えがこうし
て形になったのだと思います
を持ち努力をされてきた先人たち
その方々の恩恵を受けて私たちは今こう
やって生きています
それは私は現在55歳になりますが今から
10年前の45歳の時に
自分は障害をイブをやっとスタートする
ことができました
そのようには現在私のライフワーク仕事と
なりました
その上にたどり着く前に45年かかりまし
た
そしてその夢を形にするのに10年かかり
ました
ですから私は55歳になりました
それなどの私も過去の上をいくつかご紹介
しますと
まず
8チーム頃
科学忍者隊ガッチャマンになることです
子供ですから本気でになれると思ってまし
た
ハハヌ風呂敷をなんとガールして部屋中
毎日走り回ってました
そんなことを毎日続けてましたらついに母
から静かにしなさいと拳骨をいただきまし
た
その瞬間私のうははかなく散ってしまい
ました
小学生になる頃の私にはパイロットになる
ことでした
ところがこの夢の途中で諦めてしまいまし
た
なぜならばパイロットになるためには
たくさん勉強しなければなりません
ところは私は学校の勉強が大嫌いでした
はいロップは諦めるかそれとも嫌いな勉強
するか
私は枚まずパイロット諦めましたーーー
中学生高校生になるころは macana
かやりたいことが見つからずマンボウとし
ていました
夢は目標はが日々というのは何か針はない
というか楽しくないんですよね
大人になり初めて挑戦した仕事は終わって
コンピュータ会社でのシステムエンジが
でした
まぁ当時は再選ための仕事でしたので
クールでかっこいいと思いましたと
バリバリ仕事ができるエンジニア
そんなにメールが来4年ほど頑張ってい
ましたが現実はかなり違いました
私は全く仕事ができずかなり出来の悪い扇
が見合ってました
それどころか私は大きなミスを犯して会社
に多額に損害を与えてしまい頭と自分の居
場所を失ってしまいました
由良小を失った私はぺー食を決意し今度
こそはというふうに厳しい英語の世界へ
取り込みました
ここで力をつけてお金を稼ぎたいと思い
ました
お金があれば夢が可能と思ったからです
今回は本気で頑張りました
前に市内にし遅くまで働きました
出来る限りの努力をしました
努力の甲斐がありそれ以後
私はついに全国でトップになることができ
ました
31歳の時には会社の役員にまでなること
ができ
そして収入もどんどん増えてきました
私は以前からやりたかったいろんなことを
できるようになりました
はいぺ旅行に何十回も行きました
車が好きだしたらがいろんな車を購入し
ました
が好きだしたので海見える自宅とそして
ヨットも購入しました
私は欲しいものは全て手綺麗
夢を叶えることができ最高に幸せなはず
でした
ところが違ったのです
私の心は全く満たされないならだったの
です
それどころか私の心がぽっかりと穴が開い
たままでした
仏力や出世欲ではそれは心がはが埋まる
ことはありませんでした
何かが違う何かたちはう
なぜへ私の心は埋まらないんだろう
その画面版とする状態が何年も続きました
私は考えました
夢と欲望の違いは何か
本目の今宮が自分もなぁの人々も幸せに
なるものであり心が乱されますが個人的な
欲望は満たされることはありません
目指されるどころかもっともっとと
強欲になっていきます
そんな生き方日本との試合世話になると
思いました
私は人生の後半は自分の心自分の魂が喜ぶ
夢を持ちそれに向かって頑張っていこうと
決意をしました
少しばかりですがボランティアを始めまし
た
ケニアやうなんだ後子どもたちの砂糖をさ
せて頂いたり
う番目に学校も寄贈することができました
この時の子供たちの売れそうなるがそれは
今も忘れることができません
その間中は自分の欲望を追い求めた時には
母にいることができない喜びでした
私は30代半ばにしてやっと人生で大事な
ことに気づくことができました
そして人生で大事なことに気付くことが
できた私はもう一つどうしても実現した
いうができていました
それはこれまでの日本にはない
音馬が人生を他のパの占めたのは社会人
学校をつくることでした
私は中で日本の学校教育に疑問を持ってい
ました
この日本では多くの子供たちが小さい頃
から塾に通わされ
そして学校の成績というたった一つの
物差しで
競争させられ評価をされます
そして良い高校に入れ良い大学に入れ良い
会社に入れると言われます
しかし良い大学
良い会社に入れば本当に素晴らしい人生が
なっているのでしょうか
本当に息が得る
楽しい人生が送れるでしょうか
私はこの私になるまでいろんな方の人生を
見てきましたが
現実はかなり違います
そもそも教育の目的とは何でしょ
教育の目的とは
良い会社が入ることでもなく
エリートになることでもなくましてや誰か
に課すことでもなく一言で言えば
週目で夢希望持ち
多くの中に囲まれ幸せに生きることでは
ないでしょうか
時代が変わり
多くの人が成功ではなく成功
サクセスではなくハピネスを求めている
ように感じるのです
心から幸せといえるそんな大人増やして
いきたい
そのような考えから私はビバレーション
カレッジという社会人楽おおおお作りまし
た
このラックは10年前にスタートし現在は
各地で11校となりました
今レーションあれっ人乗りバレエショップ
は解放する時原っという意味です
生徒さんが様々なしがらみから解放され
一度限りの人生を仲間と共に強く
たくましく楽しく生きていただきたい
そんなのでこの学校の名前をつけました
ちなみにこの学校では学位や資格は一切
とれません
なぜならば私たちは学歴や資格よりも
もっと大事なものがあると思っているから
です
それがハピネスベーシックスキルです
このハピネスベーシックスキルとは私が
作った造語なのですが文字通り幸せになる
ためのスキルです
多くの方が築かれていますが
学業で良い成績を収めるが悪くとシェア背
になるための暴力はこれはしないます
社会的に出征をしたりお金を稼ぐ能力と
幸せ22棟の能力
これも違います
大事なことは幸せになる暴力女ことだと
思うのです
それがハピネスベーシックスキルとはどの
ようなスキルでしょう例えば
妙観講の紐となる挨拶時間約束などの礼儀
がしっかりできること
そして
まわりの人と楽しくコミュニケーションが
とれ自らだから作りができること
自分は人生で落ち込んだときに何度でも
自分復活させる理科ラリー力
そして自分以外はパシャを愛する力
このような基礎能力も工藤です
このような基礎能力はとての重要であり
この基礎能力があってこそ
学歴や資格様々な能力も生きてくると思う
のです
逆に言えば
このような基礎能力がなければ
どんなに学歴や資格があってもそれを
うまく活用することができません
それはまるでつまりのにいろんなものを
積み上げるようなものです
喃語を積まれても崩れていきます
霧いえば根っこの部分です
大きな木は根っこがしっかりしてるから
こそ強い風のパラルールです
とかく侍る表面的なものに目が行きがちな
世の中ですが本当に大丈夫は思いません
そして非常に地味だものです
そのような観点から
工学校の軽く塩はちょっと変わっています
一部ご紹介しますと成長とあるか
しあわせって何
そして自分の軸の作り方
このような事業を各地で行っています
+の様子ですご覧の通り蔵さんとても楽し
そうです現在は二十歳から69歳馬の方が
皆さんとの楽しく通われています
学ぶ g 年齢は関係ありません大人こそ
自分の人生をただし歌がに大いに学ぶべき
だと思います
放課後タイムのマミーケーションが
カラオケ大会も盛んです皆さんかなりリ
バレイションされています
毎年忘年会を行います見ての通りかーなー
り編です
この中には管理職の方々も大勢
いらっしゃいます
ちなみにうちの学校の忘年会は
楽しかった1年間を忘れる必要はない
前向きに生きようということで臨むとしの
会の忘年会と言います
修学旅行に毎年行います
自由参加ですがのんマン参加者が増えて
いっています
何年前に任官学校での自然教室も始めまし
たここには大人が全力な急ぎます私も戦力
で遊びますよく遊びすぎて生徒さんに注意
をされます
さてここまでは私がいかにして自分は生涯
の夢にたどり着いたのかっていう話をさせ
ていただきましたが本日はもう一つはして
もお伝えしたいことがあります
それはまず私がこの意味の実現できたのか
ということです
血流が先に申しますと
この学校を始めたとき私には何もありませ
んでした
すでに前の会社も辞めていましたので半年
以上収入がゼロでした
それから私は学歴がありません
一応工業高校は出ておりますがほとんど
勉強はしていません
特別な資格がのってありませんし勤務ない
死角のない学歴マネー
ただそんな私にもある2つの武器があり
ました
それは2つのたからまだと言っても良いか
もしれません
私にはそれがあったからこそこの夢を実現
できたように思います
の2つの武器2つの宝物とはそれが情熱
そして仲間です
まず情熱
情熱エンジンです
私はこの学区を始めた時すでに45歳でし
た
それもね色んな事がありましたが私の中に
はまだ15熱が残っていました
私はまだやれる必ずこのバックを形にする
そんな強い思いがありました
人は面々に環境学
情熱を失ったときに人生そのものを失うの
だと思います
そしてもう一つの武器
それが仲間です
私は素晴らしい仲間に恵まれました
そして私には素晴らしいパートナーがい
ました
この方です
苦楽を共にした高町です
こう学校始めの時約2年間赤字が続きまし
た
私は経営者としてこの高松市に
最低限の給料しか出すことができません
ですよ
それでも高松市は一切文句を言わず前に来
たのそうに仕事をしていただきました
このパカな父の存在は9して今はありませ
ん
この高松市は現在善行を学長されています
ちなみに今日は名古屋港に入っていただい
てますおそらく今頃カラオケをしていると
思います
その後もいろんなかなが協力をしてくれ
ました
このようにして私たちの学校は少しずつ
少しずつですがまるで幅が広がるように
宣告で形になってきました
そして当時協力協力をしてくれば仲間たち
は
現在各校の講師やスタッフとなられ生徒
さんに寄り添いながら共に成長されてい
ます
嬉しい報告もたくさんいただきました
出世される方やお給料が上がることが
たくさん増えてきました
このようにカップルが音声誕生しました
結婚される方のたくさん出てきました
そして何より嬉しいのが生徒さを褒めて
いただけることです
多くの方から生徒さん元気で前向きでいい
ですね
皆さん礼儀正しいですねと言っていただけ
ます
この学校をつくってこんなにうれしいこと
はありません
私は情熱となかな
この2つを武器に夢を形にしていきました
まずは所が熱歩きです
情熱を持つ子にお金がかかりません
学籍や資格も必要ありません
年命さえは関係ありません
そして強い上越があれば一人また一人と
素敵な仲間が集まってきます
それはまるで火ののあるに自然と人が
集まるように仲間が増えていきます
その時きっと馬に彼が始まります
最後になりますが私は常々人の衣装とは1
本のろうそくだと考えています
長いの食短い凹足100面の人生50年の
人生いろんな人生があるでしょう
その中では失敗や挫折もあるかもしれませ
ん
時にな
心火が小さくなってそうになることがある
かも知れます
ただこの命のロウソクは誰しも1本限りな
のです
私も自分の命のロウソクがあとどれくらい
残っているのかそれは彼は自分でわかり
ませんが
ただ一つ心に決めていることがあります
それはせっかく両親にいただいた子の命を
最後の最後まできれいに燃やし尽くすこと
です
さらに言えば自分のためだけではなく誰か
のため夜中のために燃やし尽くしたいと
考えています
今世界もそしてこの日本も
このなの影響より多くの方が大変な状況の
中にいます
特に若い方は夢が持ちづらい世の中なのか
もしれません
今さえ良ければ
刹那的になることがあるかもしれません
周りに流されてしまうことがあるかもしれ
ません
しかしそんな時代だからこそ夢を持って
ほしいのです
私も含め人間はとても弱い生き物です
最も簡単に流されていきます
最も簡単に自分だけそうになります
そんなときに自分を支えてくれるのが
ゲンガー理想
そして良きなかなと思うのです
皆さんのたった1本の命のロウソク
その命のロウソクが最後の最後で皆さん
らしく美しく燃え続け
夢外気が喜びに満ち溢れを人生であること
を願っていますありがとうございました
[拍手]